in France a second night of anger and
confrontation
there is Fury here over the killing of a
teenage boy by police tensions worsened
by mistrust of authority
here in Montana fireworks are used to
ward off the police while the streets
are blocked by Flames that light up the
area
among the other places were anger
spilled over with the police struggling
to keep control
there have been clashes between police
and residents in towns and cities across
France but this place nonte Remains the
focal point because this of course was
the Catalyst for all the disorder that
has followed and what you've seen
tonight are more of these big fires
being staged in roads around this whole
District
and it started with this
a teenager shot dead after police stop
his car in the Paris suburb of nontier
he tried to drive off moments later the
car crashes a passenger is stopped and a
nation reacts
the policemen have both been arrested
they're in custody and an investigation
has been launched
the victim a 17 year old called nayel
mourned by his mother
I've lost a 17 year old child they took
my baby
he was still a child he needed his
mother this morning he gave me a big
kiss and told me he loved me I said be
careful and told him I love him
her son's killing lit a fire that has
long been simmering in Paris suburbs
where crime racism and hatred of the
police are chronic problems that anger
won't be lanced easily in montair and
across France tension is simmering
Adam Parson Sky News
well that was Adam's report and he's now
sent the latest from montaire
this morning France is waking up after
another night of clashes around the
country in Lil and Toulouse and
predictably here in non-terre the Paris
suburb that was the Catalyst for all the
disorder that has followed behind me
over there you can see fires burning in
the middle of the street we can see Riot
police officers there and in fact just
walking past us here and the smell of
tear gas still lingers this is not going
to end easily and why well because this
area and all of France has now seen that
video of a French police officer
shooting a teenager in a car just a mile
or so from where I'm standing now that
has been condemned by the president by
the interior Minister by prominent
individuals including kylian mbappe the
super famous French footballer who grew
up also in a French suburb and what has
happened is a synthesis of all the
discontent by people who live here about
what they see is the brutality of the
police about the way that they think
that the system has forgotten and hasn't
given them jobs or education has left
them behind in the economy and that
discontent has clearly simmered and
boiled over here driven by the fury over
the killing of this 17 year old what
will now happen is a March from the
prefecture here in ontare led by the
mother of the teenager who died the
question here in Monte and for all of
France is whether this discontent will
continue or whether it will simmer out
and right now nobody knows the answer to
that